hey there in this video we discuss our
thoughts on the Xbox 2020 stream event
and if you enjoyed this conversation you
should check out GameSpot after dark our
weekly podcast where we talked at length
about all the biggest news in gaming
temor did x give it to you oh my god x
absolutely did not give it to me the
problem he has is we went in there being
told it was going to be a meaty look at
gameplay and instead of getting that
maybe partly it's our expectations we
got a quick cut through a bunch of games
now I don't want to devalue the fact
that they were all big new IPs and a lot
of them look really interesting score
looks amazing don't looks okay
bright memory infinite looks fine for
like we didn't get any any luck really
meet he looks at gameplay same four
assassins like assassins was the big
ticket and it was I mean we saw glimpses
of it more than an actual like his a you
know 5-10 minute look at gameplay I came
away from it with no indication of what
makes the power of the Xbox Series X
interesting for gameplay which is a
shame yeah well I mean all the games
they pretty much all the games they
talked about right have that what do
they call it Xbox up scenario said it
like eight times they said probably more
than eight times actually written this
one trillion times delivery or something
oh all the games for the most part have
that which is like cool but at the same
time it's like okay so then these games
aren't really showing us the true
potential of the series X because all
these games are also optimized for Xbox
one X I don't know exactly how it works
I mean it's like surely I mean surely
you add it and it gets you buy the game
it gets added to your Xbox account maybe
they give you a code if you buy it on
disk so you can like lock it to your
account and so when use I count on your
series X it'll like work the thing that
I think they would have needed to really
show the power of this series X would be
comparisons in load times but then
that's difficult to do because then
you're essentially
painting your current console that you
are still wanting people to be buying
because you're having the excited Punk
version come out this summer that you're
painting that in a slightly negative
light so I honestly don't think we're
gonna get that kind of comparison until
later in the year when they're fully
ramping up this showcase this morning to
play devil's advocate in a way because
like obviously what they were promising
wasn't great but I think if you compare
it to the original Xbox one launch and
like reveal this is night and day and it
kind of just shows this great evolution
of Xbox as a company and yeah I think
they got the wording definitely wrong
as soon as I saw that Assassin's Creed
trailer and there was still the
widescreen borders I was like I guess if
you're paying once - if you're paying
blur Studios millions and millions to
make your CGI trailer you get the
absolute most out of our CGI trailer but
that was maybe I think that big misstep
from this presentation but everything
else like I think the humor the hey
here's this massive list of every
company that we're working with that's
really good that putting games first I
think what we expected was meaty
gameplay but what they gave us was a
bunch of new games which i think is like
super exciting I think if you'd like to
take a step back like Lucy said and
really think about it it's considerably
better than what they was inand and I
don't want to pit them against Sony but
we've seen what Sony did was their
approach where it was very technical and
a lot of people were like ok but what
about the games and Microsoft are kind
of like you know curved out that
discussion very early by I'm showing off
games and a lot of them look really cool
that was I think one thing one very
positive thing I had walking away from
this was that there was a lot of new IPs
- I think the oh I'm in like you've got
madden of course and you've got dirt
five will get into these later and the
vampire vampire the masquerade
bloodlines witcher sequels a but like
most of the games they showed off seemed
like you know pretty big budget new IPs
which is always my favorite part about
new generations and well a lot of the
new IPs that come out these new games
aren't the greatest it's still really
cool to see what sticks what doesn't
all these new ideas and like watch
people set like the new I don't know I
guess standard for next gen it that that
was interesting I was exciting Kelly
what were your overall thoughts of it
yeah I mean not much different than what
we've already said I I mean it's kind of
hard to show off like visual fidelity
fidelity over stream because it depends
on the the viewers like internet quality
when you're talking about like this is
game play on series X I'm not really
getting that full effect I guess to
bring up the first game bright memory
infinite which they showed off that I
looked at that trailer after the fact
that did a 4k trailer and it looked way
better than what I saw on the stream and
it looked pretty impressive and
especially considering it's a game made
by one person right did I hear that
correct yes that games been flown about
for a little while and it's been
building some buzz and I think the big
news is it's coming to series X it's an
impressive game from one person and
really speaks to like how much engine
technology has come how far it's come
and that one person can take an engine
and and you know use assets available
and create something like this I'm not
saying like he's just copying pasting or
this person who is is copying and
pasting but like it's for one person to
do it is incredibly impressive well
first to look at that good is even more
impressive
yeah like the weather effects and like
the rain blowing around was super
impressive that looks interesting right
it gave me titanfall vibes
honestly just seeing the wall running
and even the sight of a gun I thought
was helpful to actually the way that the
would you call it Pathfinder sort of
from apex move me oh I read ugh that I
was like interested in score and I
thought scorn
I mean like you really see a lot of
swarm but I was like oh I like creepy
stuff mmm so cool looks amazing - about
scorn so there was something that was
floating out from about 2016 that people
were sharing onto it after the of been
I've never heard of it before I think
yeah it showed up
when it showed up it was lucky maybe a
year of those well we showed up again
it's like a Metroidvania style game with
a lot of obviously heavily inspired by H
R Giger 's work so because of that it
will look a lot like alien to people and
it's designed by studio code developed
by Assyria called AB so it's like some
sort of dreamlike world and there's like
loads of interconnected regions that you
can like explore in in a free-form way
like a Metroidvania would let you do and
then it's like unlocking skills and
weapons as you go along so the typical
Metroidvania format but within a HR
Giger keiko style theme which sounds
amazing I was I mean this trailer was
like what 10 past 8:00 this morning PT I
was like love to see that phallic
symbolism Wow
and dripping in there having sex as well
in there I was surprised honestly and
then you got you got the yonex and
symbolism in there too mm-hmm which is a
word that I enjoy because nobody's knows
that word even though they know what
phallic means Yannick oh I know it's
just that it's the opposite other one
yeah Oh sense it was a mystic I was like
this isn't like for this is a lot for 8
a.m. but I am I'm like here for it I
guess to move back a little bit after
bright memory infinitive a showed off
the fifth dirt game which I think I
played dirt - it didn't look all that
different from previous that like I was
I wasn't looking for dirt I was looking
for filth if you know I'm saying like I
needed to see the textures I need to see
the car and instead we just caught I
mean I'm sure it's it looks it looks fun
I mean I'm not your your audience here
yes I mean I think it's interesting
they've got Troy and Nolan involved yeah
that was a revealer wasn't see coming
yeah I'm kind of sad that they're just
voicing like people I kind of was
embracing like like that I wanted him to
voice the cause like to rival cause
that's not exactly
thing cause it also looked like it sound
like they like shoved a recording device
in their in their face filter recording
their lines but say this for us please
we're like have this we have this Xbox
thing we have to do they're like I'm
excited to be in codemasters new video
game and it's like cool that's all it
was like I'm happy to be in duh-duh 5-1
choice next one we saw was course Rises
won this game looks interesting I think
I was more interested in it and until I
found out that it seems like a space
combat game and I was like I don't know
if I'm super into flying spaceships
around maybe there's more to it than
that but the story seems interesting
there are a couple things I wanted to
say about this trailer first of all I
loved that she had the eyebrows lit this
girl ass but also I like that this game
abides by the chipper jizz rules of
spelling yes yes yeah yeah because I was
like service it took me a good amount of
time to be like oh I mean chorus no this
a weird I'm saying it now official
GameSpot standard is to call it chore
this is known this power guide Elon Musk
and Grimes ago mmediately thought of
them I was like yep that's that's that's
that one tick tock many years from now
but like the story seems cool like she's
some sort of single-handed Savior for
some maybe all of the mankind or
something like that it sounded like that
but then it [ __ ] his ships and then I
was like oh I guess I guess you saved
everyone using a ship cool
alright so I've dedicated a lot of time
to talk about this next one Madden 21
anyway the next game on the list I think
one of the ones I'm most excited for
here is vampire the masquerade
bloodlines two big drive ib's from this
trailer I know like especially coming
from I think what they showed at e3
right did see it was very serious and
dark and this one had
a very interesting dark sense of humor
to it well when I first saw it I thought
it was a wee happy for you because yes
the smiles was the darkness because it's
thoughts of open logo for like nose like
no another band I thought you meant the
band I'm so excited for the original
yeah it's hard to play these days but I
love that original one that was so good
I reminded me a kind of I treated like
as if I was in the TV show angel because
it was just like an LA like see wears
loads of vampires and societies and that
kind of stuff we needed rolling around
still worth playing if you work have you
seen interviews at the I think either
the lead writer creative director for
that game no he looks like the kind of
person that would write or directed game
about vampires yeah but like like the
interview I saw he was wearing like
fingerless gloves and like he was like
all wearing all black and I was like
right he was very pale and I was like
looks like should make that thing well
if you're a developer working on a
camera interview have to dressed in
theme with the game so you're like
interviewing a quality a developer in
like full military regalia the next one
call of the sea which looks interesting
it looks a lot like a sea of thieves
style game but it looks like it's more
story focused I was shocked
yeah we're Bioshock to you like it's
like all of that what you just said but
also like our wild I feel like there's
gonna be a lot of games are like our
worlds like now so watch I want to see
more of it because I felt like the art
style didn't match the narration maybe
that's a weird thing that like homie I
would care about but like it was like
dearest Henry and then like the art was
kind of like colorful and cartoony yeah
and I mean I know Pete there's a lot of
fatigue on like grim dark gritty stuff
but I like grim dark gritty stuff so I
was like where are the clouds but then
this one this one
it's turned into the shape of water
because you saw the amphibious kind of
hands at the end so maybe it'll go there
okay no see that that's all I need it
now I'm more invested yeah I couldn't
think of the webbing would you would you
call that wedding yeah hands for your
pleasure the ascent a top-down cyberpunk
shooter Oh
cyberpunk eNOS listen yeah I'm playing
this but there's only room for one
cyberpunk in my heart right now and we
all know which one that one is but this
looks cool I think this looks cool I was
tricked stylistically it looked fairly
cooled but I think that the top-down
stuff kind of lost me I was like I don't
know if I want it yeah like intro like
cinematic sequences I was like okay
aliens
cyberpunk and then the top-down stuff I
was kind of like not as jazzed about but
yeah I don't know if anyone played
ruiner but that was a top-down cyberpunk
Shiva that was really good so looking at
that like obviously look like two
different games different styles and all
that kind of stuff but I don't know I
was like I think I got my filled with
ruiner I'd be more I don't know yeah
top down didn't do it for me there's
nobody played too much much TV back in
the day I love me some top-down so I
think that's why I'm like alright
alright next up here is the medium the
horror game from blooper team the ones
who did observer observer observer and
in Blair Witch did you guys play
observer and/or Blair Witch
I play laser fear but no language okay I
didn't play observer but I played Blair
Witch which I which I thought was good
everything liked it the one with the dog
companion right yeah the one with the
dark companion they they they make
really cool games though so I'm
interested in seeing so we we actually
have an interview with developers from
Bluebird team up on our site it's
conducted by Steve watts
and they kind of spoke about what they
would so this is a game that they had
the idea for they say in 2012 but they
said they couldn't make it because the
tech wasn't there in place until now
everyone says that it's like yeah a
classic day one how do we make our game
look cool but they seem to be very into
the the kind of tech to the point where
in our interview they mentioned that
they have something in their game that
they pretty much described as
revolutionary to the point where they're
patenting it and so they wouldn't talk
to us about it but they were like we're
not there already to talk about it and
they kind of teased it in in the actual
interview they do during the inside xbox
so I'm intrigued to see what that is at
the very least basically yes yeah keep
an eye on that our money trophy
scarlet Nexus anime game and you Kelly
let's do this
proper shite
I kid I kid
it looks like it looks like what was
that last anime dark souls games that he
made code vein vein it looks like they
very quickly prepared from Cobain and
something else yeah I did get that vibe
I this is another one where the start of
the trailer I was like okay okay cuz it
had these like flower monsters now yeah
okay that's pretty cool and then they
hit me with the like they couldn't be
hurt until now like alright and the
characters voice as well like it really
stuck out as being awkward the now place
it was one that I I wish they had gone
with the Japanese dub just because I
feel like it would have been less of a
jarring transition from the like drama
of the intro to that trailer too like
the Shonan like young boy voice like
teenage boy voice of the protagonist and
I think maybe because the audience for
this isn't Japanese speaking a Japanese
voice over would have been a little bit
easier but then yeah because it was in
Japanese
so maybe that was maybe there was just
bandai's decision and not Xboxes yeah
possibly I mean like the thing uh I mean
I'm definitely gonna keep an eye on it
because anime game but like like the the
telekinesis side of it whenever games do
like physics based telekinesis around
combat I'm always into it like ever
since I ops and and like more recent
stuff as well like control has a bit but
lovely actually I love that stuff
so I'm definitely keeping out on it but
like it very much like Timmy I was like
this looks kind of code veiny to me and
code veiny let me down in a big way so
Yakuza yeah cos are like a dragon and
about this is why everyone's here for a
see this is what I showed up for a we
you know what I assume we're allowed to
talk about it but when we went to Atlas
last year to shoot something for persona
we sat down with the devs and they
played a bunch of like a dragon yeah and
that game is that [ __ ] I love it I think
the thing that's been for a lot of
yuppies our fans they've been trying to
figure out where it's positioned because
obviously curious stories ended but it
looks like he will be around because
they showed mad you mind that yeah so
I'm currently replaying the Yakuza
series so I'm very in user mode so I'm
excited for that
anyway lastly they wrapped up with
Assassin's Creed of all holla some hot
gameplay oh wait we missed we missed
extinction was it sick Oh a second
extinction reclaim earth but I thought
was toric and then it wasn't
Oh Tarak that's what I meant to put in
that Dino Crisis I feel like people have
been wanting a new turret
Tarak for a long time and and everyone's
like yeah I just want to like fight
dinosaurs in a first-person shooter game
and then after seeing that I was like I
don't actually want that but I don't
know I'll play it it looks fun guess I
just didn't quite get why people really
wanted it a new turret game yeah I I
just that trailer like I was asleep I
don't want to hurt these creatures like
it's just I don't know if it was like I
watching that trailer I was like why am
i okay we shooting people but not
dinosaurs
I should examine that that's that's the
only takeaway I have Assassin's Creed
Valhalla it was a shorter game yeah it
wasn't very much gameplay in the
traditional sense but continues to look
cool I fully expected from the way they
were talking about it I was expecting to
see like a raid or something like a full
510 minute demo at the end in Assassin's
Creed Valhalla you play as evil John
Martin that's what we wanted oh we do
that but you've Aesop's gotta just be
holding on to all that stuff for their
stream whenever that happens it's like
yeah we're gonna save the good stuff
which I understand but at the same time
considering they market it as gameplay
it's kind of like well you know
technically I guess you should yeah
Twitter right now is like not happy
gameplay it's just tried doing bites up
I think a lot of people are pissed
games are angry at the same time it's
like I get being kind of annoyed that
they didn't show gameplay but it's like
it's an assassin's Creed game right like
they're gonna show gameplay soon it's
gonna come out before the end of the
year like you'll play it for a month or
two and then you'll move on and think
about the next cess agreed like it's
fine it's fine gameplay will be there
don't worry and also like you have to
take into account that people were doing
all like a lot of that final stuff from
home and you know that's harder to do so
it's like yeah like it's it's it's funny
to dunk on like it's clearly just
Microsoft and Ubisoft didn't really
think about it they were like oh yeah
this is gameplay and they didn't realize
it would be a bit of a backlash cuz it's
like I don't know a couple
nature shots moving slowly this is kinda
like okay like I imagine probably it's
just not ready and they just didn't want
to put unfinished stuff up on a
presentation with as many eyes on it as
this but yeah I'm curious to see cuz
normally with the past couple Assassin's
Creed's
at e3 we've had like an hour-long
hands-on time with them and so I imagine
at some point this summer maybe a little
later they'll
show like an extended livestream of
gameplay in that game
[Music]